what's happening you bad [ __ ]
this podcast is brought to you by on it
the best supplements out there from
halfa brain the shroom tech to the to
the to the milkshake of death the hemp
protein cocoa milkshake it will rock
your world go to Anna comrade now press
your church and get 10% off your first
order this podcast is also brought to
you by zip recruit it when you're
looking at higher zip recruit calm is
the way to go right now we're going to
give you a free zip recruiter account so
all my listeners can post jobs on zip
recruiter for free by going to zip
recruiter dot-com slash church also on
this podcast is my favorite tushy
listen why walk around with a stinky ass
you understand me
you got pushy they're back the days
portable ones you got four bathrooms you
got four bad days no more you have to
walk around with stinky balls if your
little monkey smells like a your onion
and you want to go on a dinner date boom
watch that onion hello - she calm get
10% off right now by president Church
whoa there you have it welcome to the
church [ __ ]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] Monday May first do you think it
deal with guys professional music right
here this [ __ ] kicked at me leave Monday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here we go here we go boom
here we go [ __ ]
the church - what's happened now Monday
May 1st
coming at you oh [ __ ] here we go um
always in jeopardy got something oh [ __ ]
on some beautiful [ __ ] day to
be alive and you're making it happen
welcome to the Church of what's happened
now uncle Joey li Ren is easy and my
main little [ __ ] goombah Lisa at as
usual was a beautiful weekend here in
Southern California where were you I was
in in Columbus Ohio this weekend I was
the weather
ah rainy rainy a little rainy little
humid a little rain in your life yeah
just a little bit we say out how was
your weekend toes in my weekend I was
boring
yeah well I went I went to the ice house
which was great so we have a good time
baby o'clock show in a clock show and
other than that just kind of laughs yeah
didn't do much you have the Celtics I
miss that stuff I love I just like what
like when I'm watching because I don't
know any of the players anymore I'm a
Celtics I know maybe two or three of
them I just like watching like the fans
because I just reminds me I'm going
there as a kid they're good and they got
a good stories here that kid you know
lost his sister right that one sort of
you know on their bandwagon they're good
but they're good they're sneaky good and
I don't know anything about basketball
but I liked a few like that seven years
ago when they won because it seemed like
they were doing like kg was doing short
shots like maybe layups and some dunks
and Paul Pierce or Ray Allen two or
three everyone on the Celtics team is
shooting nothing but three yeah they're
all in on that game it bums me I mean
it's great when you win but it's a new
philosophy yes but how crazy don't know
what the [ __ ] you guys are talking about
golly just shooting three-pointers I
know banging them out there and watch
basketball the playoffs at all like
somebody just told me when I'll be in
Utah Golden State's going to be in town
they got ya thursdaya Saturdays yeah
they're they're playing family who wants
to play Ashley I think I watched Alonzo
Bodden was on a talking about the
[ __ ] Clippers yeah watch them they're
just a nightmare
yeah they just lost to Utah Utah that's
why are you talking about just a [ __ ]
everything tightens up a little bit in
the playoffs it's a further you get so
those threes aren't as open as much so
the better defensive better better team
usually ends up winning but before we
have his podcast on I want to talk about
something last week you know we had
Carlos lien seeing on why he called he
called he apologized he talked like a
man I could have had him on the show
and asked him about this so I asked him
about that I asked him about this we all
know one of them the result we all heard
the story already I didn't want to take
the horse there I wanted to take the
cohorts down a different path he told
you what he felt
you saw where his head was and that's
when we started to show that's what this
show was about was about second [ __ ]
chances who gives a [ __ ] just keep movin
with your life somebody apologized he
called you also right um no he didn't
call me
I thought he called when is easier now
called your son no he called a couple
guys and apologize for his behavior at
the store and stuff like that you know
so yeah it took us a nice little Hey and
then what look as someone who's made mr.
mistakes
I can't what am I gonna do and oh you
know I'm one of those people men that if
it wasn't for I got told Joe two days
later I go you know how many people who
give me [ __ ] chances are you hitting
me
are you [ __ ] kidding me I'm here
because of chances I'm not here because
I'm lucky
mm-hmm or because I outwitted somebody
I'm here because somebody turned an eye
and I said I'm not gonna do that again
and eventually have to $200 you get
stronger and [ __ ] strong I'm saying
this was a community project from me but
it's just weird how some people do
[ __ ] up [ __ ] in the country and for
three years I never saw the guy from
Seinfeld again when I got it Rick
Michael Richard yeah he tripped through
the tirade at the Laugh Factory like I
never saw him again
well some people I don't know
stand-up is important to some people to
continue to do it after you've made an a
public thing you know and I'm not
putting any I don't know what how
important it is to him but you know I'm
saying like maybe it's he's probably
done other things but maybe going on
stage stand up wise is not something he
does anymore you know I don't know but
you know if you keep that's what you do
they need to step three what we could
not do what you do anymore
no I know listen man it's just uh I
don't one day something getting
criticized I having a tiger would Hannah
like in the media uh-huh he said you
know how can you trust somebody who
backs Tiger Woods that Tiger Woods was
[ __ ] a kid with what I said went down
you can't judge a man's life but the
actions he does when were [ __ ] kids
when were twenty five thirty when you
you know I was watching a pile of clay
and I'm starting to talk about it on
stage
mm-hmm how fifty is a [ __ ] up ast
right is easy forty and fifty it's a big
difference yeah I turned 40 this year
yeah you're running I creams a month and
a half you're running on fumes the
beauty is you know it before do you
running on fumes
yeah i am xited know it yeah I kind of
know it and you kind of feel it and
you're you're thinking of a stumble on
to something and that will take you to
the next level but at 50 you see that
the 20s it was just a big mistake
like the 20s is just a mistake son
mistake a mistake in the sense that you
did everything down the choice you could
pocket make think give us all this
freedom between the ages of 17 and
toiling and we're [ __ ] morons 90% but
I would argue the fact that what if you
made every single [ __ ] right choice
and that your 20s right and your 50s and
you're going I met you could be making
every poor choice then because you never
[ __ ] made all those dumb mistakes
well that happens also dad's also some
okay you're born your parents own a
construction company
yeah billions of dollars you know what
you work 10 hours a week they give you
to say these beds instead of doing you
no favors you want to around the world
you know you can have a splinter in your
[ __ ] hand
your brother's Rover there
[ __ ] slaving in the [ __ ] things
and then I would build in [ __ ]
buildings you know yeah and you know
what man when you're 38 something
happens that one of your brothers has a
gambling problem and you didn't know
about it awesome when they come and shut
the [ __ ] thing so your bandwagon is
done you gotta get you got to build now
you know now you have to do somebody
your [ __ ] life
and now you've never done anything even
haven't done anything you have no life
experiences but going to parties yeah I
know how to make a margarita no people
skills you know and that's when your
life tightens because those people from
the party world they're just as
worthless as you are so there's no help
there
no you catch your first uh that's your
first [ __ ] blow that your friends
these friends you have over the years
that you thought when they when you have
a bound to blow plenty people call you
doesn't take much you want more then
people call you are giving out to blow
and put it on Twitter I get people come
at the outer limo you're the best guy
they have a threat they love Jews you
know yeah yeah you know they love
whatever you want it love [ __ ] weird
how yeah and now I see how from being
here for 20 years you start to see
things and you start to see patterns
like a young guy with a big ego I don't
even pay attention because I see the
crash coming I see the wall about to hit
them you don't not even that needs to do
anything
some young actors gets in your face and
calls you a bunch of names you just
giggle and you know give it time but
then three years some will have even
these fears we also what happened with
Britney Spears the six years Britney
Spears couldn't cross the street without
getting in trouble getting tortured she
made it all go away thinking about
Britney Spears she made it all go away
mm-hmm she ain't a nobody all she just
disappeared yeah she just got away from
them they couldn't they didn't give a
[ __ ] she's still irrelevant you want to
check Forbes and see what she made last
year oh yes you get that Vegas [ __ ] if
the biggest honor she's a real relevant
no I'm saying she's still relevant you
know she's the relevant [ __ ] oh oh
check up [ __ ] paper a little paper
hits 100 million a year she went this is
her last year well she
probably turning what is she I would say
3234 know she's old in that hive I mean
I'm turning 40 and I said she was a kid
at you know when I read early six maybe
Britney Spears probably 36
yeah 36 so maybe you know they never
retire I'm turning 36 in December [ __ ]
you think you're dealing with some
novice and choix man come on then you're
talking I think with guns and roses made
210 million dollars from April to April
be dead for touring that's crazy
listen man 50 60 80 off to go I went to
a DC with Triple E at Dodger Stadium on
a [ __ ] Monday sold out $51 was the
cheapest ticket I heard anyone say that
they had sold out and they were doing
you know a hundred shows a year we oh
you got a little if you get more at 51
[ __ ] dollars for the cheapest ticket
for the cheapest one on a Monday okay so
I go up to I don't know how many
featured I just a those real tickets
they probably put I don't make money so
music anymore no I got a tour so they
got a bang at the gate like [ __ ]
animals to keep it together 56,000 for
baseball games I don't know what holds
for so they pride its 540 with all the
equipment and everything here think
about this though it's like you think
those guys want to still be out there
[ __ ] I mean I know that they do and
they the ship here's the show when we
all breathe it was unbelievable but it
was like one two like they would sing
something thunderstruck and then it
would take like a 15-minute break and
then you would hear like doo-doo-doo but
an explosion and then the next song so
it was like 10 songs with like 10
minutes in between it wasn't like they
were pounding the mountains you could
tell they're tired
well little deal in between songs like
rest or you know drink water catch their
[ __ ] breadstick they're set you know
in their late 60s on a ac/dc yeah look
up what uh what's his name is he's got
to be Angus Young he's got only 57 right
now I would for you he's in he's 62 -
Angus Young see how old Angus is the
[ __ ] singer yet he's 10,000 Brian
Johnson that's why they threw him is
I saw his ass on the Vitamix them with
you so what axel wrong 6262
XD [ __ ] - yeah you think he wants to
be out there every [ __ ] night I mean
and he does yes but it's like I don't
know the record label called them I
think if you as we give you a view it
would be great if they could do an album
a year and then that made 10 million and
then they didn't have to go on the road
they could do [ __ ] you know 30 great
shows and you know or not across the
world they know as much as you know it
you don't want to hear [ __ ] dick
no now you don't want to hit dick no
when you go see a CPA CDC has five
albums with the original singer and then
like eat more with Brian Johnson I'm
just saying I have no idea they have a
repertoire that's [ __ ] huge you know
they know if they go into the studio for
four years or two years and buy material
and rehearse it and it's it's the
directors that have a cell you know they
could just make compilations and live
albums that's how good they are
yeah the band's like that of that gal
but can still do a live out they've done
it they've been around though I seen
ac/dc in nineteen [ __ ] eighty what
does that tell you that's how long we go
nineteen eighty ninety two thousand two
thousand ten that's 37 [ __ ] years ago
oh yeah there's the summer of 79 I saw
him with Ted Nugent at the garden they
were opening up for 10:00 on the highway
to hell tour opening up one of the
hottest albums in the country and they
were opening up for Madison Square
Garden August 4th 1970 [ __ ] 9:00 this
is how deep my Jimmy rolls and you know
what I went there with I went there with
this girl I was not date that I just
asked her it apart if you want to go see
ac/dc and she said yeah I got the
tickets for like 12 bucks 12 bucks
you know red six tickets that's like in
debts I mean can you still see D New
York right it's still like papa
you know like [ __ ] like you know not
clean with no x squared X in 1979 is 72
door rugs on the walk yeah yeah you
could get high this is something that if
I could have a chronological on a film
like just to walk like what you had to
do like what would be was Steve what is
easy and Coco do on the wall of your
place to do the guard like the whole
thing you would meet me welcome your
house he has in North Bergen New Jersey
on the bottom of 39th Street okay okay
so my mom would be going on in those
days you come over and I take a Heineken
from my mom and we split it uh-huh
I'd already have 20 joints rolled
pre-roll don't have anything we already
had tickets and I'm saying and we maybe
had THC crystal I'm not sure so what we
did was so like Lux we walked to the
part to see if we gonna write up to help
yep
if somebody gave us a round to hell we
gave them a joint mm-hmm the hill can
I'll show you I go home you know the
hell I'm talking about from the cemetery
om - Kelly bull I gotta go past the
crazy guy we talked but the Chinese
start a Chinese store that he'll voice a
degree he'll oh this is brutal
this is [ __ ] brutal but if there's
nobody at the park we're [ __ ] now we
got to walk up you know we're gonna walk
up to buy the Chinese store and that's
what we first get our first drink of
water
Thanks and then we walk up to Kennedy
Boulevard on Kennedy Boulevard by the
university it always be three or four
guys hanging outside we go up to the
look dog go inside and get me a beer and
that was all like that yeah yeah how old
are you from is like st. worth toast
fresh means going into sophomore year
invincible we would stop at the
University and I was two years old in
1917 to be 90 jig Sugata whatever you
know of them two guys would give us
beers and then we drink those beers
walking into the bus that was another
3/4 mile walk there was a hotdog stand
before the bus you got yourself a salmon
I'm doing dinner so you had something
you still got maybe wouldn't queue
follow those a but it was a pretty fog
yeah and then you you know you could eat
for the rest of the night but you know
you got something right now and then you
ran that [ __ ] bus because every two
minutes is a bus to New York City that's
the last stop before the bus is going to
New York City so it's buses from the
boundary shortly going to New York City
you're on a bus whatever you get on that
bus and all of a sudden you hear ac/dc
music you see somebody in the back
because you know they're going to F
ucking going yeah oh you camaraderie you
just felt this even though you know you
look at them for a while you can hear
their Lily Lily headphones not even this
was this one 7 yeah oh yeah there's a
highway down yeah the only song you
heard and then you got off the port
authority you walk downstairs you walked
outside and from the minute you hit 42nd
Street whatever the [ __ ] that is in
Times Square right there like a block
away you would hear a mild ac/dc and you
would walk those six eight blocks to the
god with people running past you going
man we're going to see [ __ ] Angus and
you're like wow look at New York [ __ ]
City
you know they were reading a closer you
get to this garden like we'd be walking
on the side with the post office across
regardless the world's whatever yeah
that's a burn up 8th Avenue side right
and we'd walk up and it'd be you know
hundreds of people outside with no
tickets no money to go in just party yep
planning the vibe that can't happen time
even if you wanted to I mean people
would [ __ ] ghetto blasters on the
street drinking smoking pot doesn't
afford the drunk 14 or how many cops are
around like what is the police presence
at something like that four at the door
or at the door if you don't come [ __ ]
with the door they ain't gonna [ __ ] with
you if you're not if you don't like if
you don't have a good joint you swear
the door you like yeah okay Megan oh no
no no no no there's four guys at the
door but if you're 10 people deep
towards the street yeah a martyr he
locked in you went to your seats the
warm-up band was playing you walk to
your seats and the [ __ ] actually the
band's hit the stage and
I tore that everybody sparked in those
days it was sparking people would pass
your joints you're like holy [ __ ] like
you hear about all these parties like
when I was a kid I go to Steve once you
do a stall I parties over it over it
Lee's house I didn't really understand
the concept of the word party mm-hmm
were you doing drugs and drinking with
him or was it like the parties I see on
TV were people is we had brother
Patrick's is not amused everybody
[ __ ] nobody's got a date I didn't
understand that Kanye so we know it was
when he went to that garden or like the
garden especially the garden was the one
I caught a couple good cause of death
the garden where you you know you you
had meaning for an hour yeah like your
life had meaning because all these other
$18,000 Elliot's justified that meaning
you had for whatever I want to see the
who with the God I went to see a Black
Sabbath with Van Halen open love them at
the guard yeah I want to see some great
shows at the garden Plus Nick games out
the ass cuz I want to see my favorite
thing I went to the garden is I used to
go see Julius Erving with the Sixers
come in Christmas Day and I once got
tickets from Bobby Hurley said coach
Hurley and the nepalese gave me a
[ __ ] front-row tickets on Jersey and
was Carolina playing Rutgers when they
had a black dude named Jamie Bailey to
just slam dunk on your ass I'll never
forget that going to that [ __ ] so I
really there was something about the
garden that you felt something for yeah
it's like for some people it's for the
Lakers play they went to see a bunch of
concerts that you know if you're from
Pittsburgh you want to see a bunch of
concerts at the old free River Stadium
you know there's just something about
being in those particular places my dad
took me one time it was a Martin Luther
King jr. Day so you had often but the
next always played a day game that day
so my dad took me my brother
Dolph all five SS mom and we went in
because I was I liked basketball this is
not something he it wasn't a sport but I
liked basketball so
we go and they're playing barclays
playing the Knicks or Everett Anthony
was on Phil Phoenix and there was the
game where at the end of that he got
into it with the ref he jumped at the
ref and you know if the end of the game
the game's over kind of people are
getting up to leave and UC Berkeley
jumped towards the rapping and people
and I could see my dad like all right
we're out of here let's go everyone up
come on we did ever [ __ ] due diligence
let's get on the railroad and get the
[ __ ] out of here it's crazy you never
knew like all that stuff the garden
wasn't about going to the [ __ ] game
it was about what happened mm-hmm on the
way to the game and what happened on the
way home like that was always what you
remembered those like the concert could
have been like I'll never forget one
Monday I went to school and it was one
of those East Coast days in April it's
supposed to be cold but you bring like a
winter jacket and when you come out of
school it's [ __ ] a thousand it's a
thousand you know you're like what watch
it what the [ __ ] happens the [ __ ]
newsmen did coming buy this [ __ ] now I'm
gonna carry this [ __ ] Parker home 30
blocks on a bus with a boy there's no
cloud cover no cloud cover lazing on
Glazer
another thing I hated he's up I walked
out of there and I saw this rx-7 I would
belong for this cat we called the devil
right they call it me okay his name was
Mike Danny and he was five foot two
three but he was a state champion
wrestler and he came from really freaky
family like they were boat people they
don't pay they are we know people not
invoke people like that they resurface
ships okay so when a ship does a long
haul they took to go in the Hoboken on
Newark okay and the Denny's had a
company that would come in and you don't
take away all the rust take the
barnacles off put new [ __ ] holes new
new windows you know we stock anything
because when you're out there and see
you need a [ __ ] it all that [ __ ] gets
[ __ ] sea salt in it so they would
scrub it down it was like it's about six
month process they would have three
ships at once it was it was a great
business from the family
made money but Mike was the devil like
his street name was the devil and I
liked Mike as a young age because he
wrestled he knew people I knew but every
time I went out with Mike it was always
a by the way he was one of those guys
Mike as we speak today is doing I'm a
life from murdering his wife to name the
game at the age of 14 was exactly true
when you looked at my gosh you know he
was the dough oh really
but I loved him we have come to double
to his face like I hide down some people
call the devil oh well some people go do
what he's doing in life some people just
what are you doing hanging out with the
devil and our hangout is do creepy [ __ ]
with the devil like creepy was he
violent uh he would bite you
he would hit you with a [ __ ] could he
was five foot two that's reality wait
yeah something you know he was hit you
with something would cut you he was
nobody resolved he was all those guys
he'd given 300 for an 8-ball he wouldn't
come back oh really
unreliable that yeah rough around the
edges like you got to watch him like a
[ __ ] orc and I'll never forget I come
out of TV saying he would cut you and no
one reacted to that like he would cut
you she would send you somebody yeah I
see that I think that I see him in
action a couple times in New York City
late night like or aborted
Joey reads people like you know how how
Li quarterbacks can read a defense real
quick so I think he knows when when you
know yeah I could've turned for the
worst and he knows when to get out of it
I know yeah yeah I know Holly gonna play
with I hit the bed I knew how to always
have mono
he's the Mike she chefs Kiev there was
always a by the way with her AZ people
and I always had a by the way coke will
you be gonna drive me to the city yeah
so those days I had a godmother it was
the rise in the story I told she's so
coca in 13th and Fifth Avenue by that by
by Central Park and then the daytime was
a rough neighborhood never had at night
now fall when they already liked all
these [ __ ] movies and TV what's the
one The Walking Dead yeah that's what
this was this was the Walking Dead yeah
you would double Park your calling I'd
say give me five minutes let me go
upstairs when I can
Oh Joey I'm never bringing over here
again I just saw a girl to stab my
husband I just saw a kid get rid of my
car they picked them up on the truck
it's Willow's [ __ ] neighborhoods like
a junkie just got shot no one cares
koala walking around them it was night
from 82 when I left there in 84 85 that
neighborhood was not and I would make
them nicest white people drive me over
that one of the morning I would call it
11 the list I got oh my god I know what
I'm gonna do
should go what you just lay that out
yeah I get right away she go what's the
matter I go my teacher just called and
he wants me to have these books for
class and she go how much do you need
$90 okay come over and get it and by the
time I got over there I would qualify
gonna give it a bump by the time I got
there was 200 and then she can go you
will awake and she'd go yet and she'd go
on you want a bump and I go now just
give me a small package to go and she'd
give me like a grandma blood and go a
worse coke in the world it was horrific
you could do the whole package in 1980
and nothing would happen to you it was
like doing surgery love coke nothing
would happen say thank you but you
always give me cash to buy good coke
that's what I would do yeah I good cold
I like that so the cash was for hunts
other caches for chemistry book yeah but
you know same different area middle
terrain looks a bit it's all a
chemically but I used to make the devil
drive me in weird places like I knew
people that's so cold after my mom died
and I would still keep in touch with
them at that time you have you one hand
on the arm come to the South Bronx the
only person with driving is my daddy I
don't know Mike if you drive me I'll
give you an Eightball
those that he though how do they ball
cut in my socks so I would take him a
gram and a half out and throw a gram and
a half a cut it and give it to him you
always had a w3 prepare you always had a
double-crossing because he was always
with a double-cross you hear yeah
anytime something will happen with money
with
like if we tell you he was earning your
gram for 70 bucks it was going to be 90
for half that it was going to be 6/10
like there was always a by the way but
when I first started becoming friends
I'm hearing a girlfriend that was a
model and she worked in the city so he
would drive her some [ __ ] I don't
remember the whole story but one day I
come on ice one day is and I was going
on death and he goes nothing I'm over
good children bla bla bla bla ba he goes
I was going to take my girlfriend to the
show today but she can't go and I want
to ask my creepy brother do you want to
go and I go [ __ ] you who is it he goes
to do barbarians the new barbarians was
the Rolling Stones without makjang
that's what that was
no who's the frontman Keith Richards and
Rod Stewart God and Rod Stewart
everything who ever showed up
oh really so it's like a sort of like a
Rod Stewart was sort of a needle with
Keith Richards yeah then I get he
Richards Ron Wood uh-huh Ian McLaughlin
the piano player Stanley Clarke was on
the bass and I think the drummer was the
drummer will hear it was Ron Wood and
whatever the loo barbarians but the
singers that were supposed to show up in
the 12 city tour with Robert Plant
uh-huh
not Stewart Rod Stewart and there was
somebody else nomic Jack no don't like
Jagger at all they kept it [ __ ] tight
from uncle Mick but every night they had
somebody different like somebody saying
to Hannah would show up and play with
keys or like it was a really interesting
tool so he I didn't know anything about
you want me to tell you that I knew what
the [ __ ] they were talking about I knew
the Rolling Stones I have like maybe
five al even time I didn't know that
yeah I knew the same song as you know
over the radio where was the concert in
Spain hide in the garden so that we get
there you know same thing we went got a
package he beat me out of five hours he
paid for tickets but I had to pay for
parking there was always a by the way
with the devil you know saying like
there was always once we got there we
had to get a t-shirt for his girlfriend
why would you keep going out with this
guy because he got enough it always won
I listened when I was growing up
I had four or five different variety of
friends I didn't just hang out with
Stephen is easy Steve what is easy was
my movie for it he smoked some pot he
likes movies he likes Italian food guess
what I call Steve on Sunday nights
he is my man on Sundays we go get a
slice of pizza we talk about the week
he sounds Mia's gonna give me a job
doing union construction and then we go
catch the Charles Bronson really goes
home he lives with his mother his father
Steve wouldn't break the law if you
wanted to but at the same time when
Steve and me went home at 10:00 what
some expression loose something as a
devil's workshop
loosely lit I think sheds dine on like I
wouldn't want to go oh idle time is the
devil's yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna do is
ten o'clock okay then you go gotta go
meet another kind of friend I would go
hang out with Mike deli the devil mm-hmm
I knew I was gonna do blow with him
we're gonna hit some type of drugs when
you with Mike Danny you were gonna to
put some a pill to little a bag of blow
maybe a line of heroin with anything
could go down with him well that was 16
of my mom died I didn't give a [ __ ]
about me so when I saw Mike Benny I
jumped in that [ __ ] rx-7 we had a
good ol [ __ ] time thousand ten and
90% of [ __ ] we did was robbed but again
he was one of those guys that will go
listen a ship just came in and they got
a box of watches let's go rob the white
he was that crazy so we'd have to climb
a fence behind the shipyard and [ __ ]
walk through mud with your dogs and we'd
have to go get and he knew all the
combinations and [ __ ] I think yeah how
accurate was the information always
solid I was always always something I
pay day it was always something
different there's 30 watches when I get
$100 a piece for the watches that's
three grand we'll split a 1500 you don't
have to sell the watch no all I had to
do is go steal you already had a
drop-off point next day you're not gonna
believe what happened six other watches
with dammit huh I'm only gonna get 800
you know [ __ ] like that yeah he paid you
and that was the beauty of it there was
always gonna be a [ __ ] of my boy that's
what made it interesting
the worst thing that ever happened with
me and him that always stuck in my mind
just to let you know guys it was New
Year's Day and we went to see Aerosmith
at the Nassau Coliseum Paris which was
terrible
the tickets are terrible the drive was
terrible but we were on Kelly Boulevard
and you're on the Jersey side and it had
to be maybe 12:30 at night on a Sunday
night
New Year's [ __ ] day okay who the [ __ ]
goes out and Aerosmith decides to do a
show New Year's [ __ ] day but meaning
the devil around we took a hit assets we
took like [ __ ] this powerful [ __ ]
asset at a time and I'm tripping my ass
off listening to get your wings by
Aerosmith in the car that's one of my
all-time favorite albums and I see red
lights and we pull up and it's an rx-7
just like Mike Bennett didn't hit a tree
and it hit split right through the
[ __ ] middle this guy was dead he was
fun but she was stuck okay she was stuck
now we're on acid no doesn't all this is
going on yet one I hit acid we're like
God we're like the sixth people on the
scene I would leave that scene
immediately okay will I feel like it's a
couple guys yelling and screaming Lee
are you okay and she's like help me help
me in the middle of all this an
ambulance comes along - ambulances fire
department and they had [ __ ] sores
and they're telling the girl are you
okay she's again on my boyfriend's dead
and pumping up pumping up a pot and
we're [ __ ] standing there frozen you
get pulled over and stuff yelling we
pulled over legally we don't know
whether it was yeah there was debris all
over the [ __ ] Road you were trying to
get a [ __ ] Sheena [ __ ] yeah oh yeah
somebody cut them off and then hit them
like somebody I can't yet guys I'm not a
crime investigator what I do know was
that the [ __ ] car was split in half
he was dead his size a
he was crushed his head was exploded and
there was blood everywhere and she was
still alive
Oh like it's basically but that tail had
been hit and there was another car the
window was smashed and the guy was
unconscious in the front seat
there was no airbags in those days there
was none that she'll know that was going
on that [ __ ] so we get out of the car
she's yelling the [ __ ] firemen like
get out and we get out of the way the
cops come they put a [ __ ] yellow tape
so I go back to you know it's one
o'clock in the morning just a red lights
I'm tripping my balls off with anyone
ask you any questions or anything like
that just like did you guys see anything
no we just came like right now there was
like two cops there right oh we said we
had a cop car already there and he knew
when the tea was looking at people I
can't believe you drove on acid now I'm
watching the [ __ ] aah the acid kind
of saved me because I faint when I see
blood so I she was covered in blood but
she was yelling for her life well under
the class does the passenger seat the
driver's seat that he was just weakened
like this ha ha ha ha it was like a
little like I swear to god it was just
coming from the seat like it squished
his head him what's the squished his
shoulder like I remember I couldn't see
him because the window and the car it
just dog that's why I don't like little
cars like that yeah I'm against all
little cars guys against him completely
and that's my logic that's why I saw in
1987 when cars was still cars now 1980
we knew he is 1980 maybe 1981 if I'm
wrong maybe if I'm [ __ ] wrong
so we're tripping and they get up and
they saw the car you know do you think I
had to show y'all the life and they did
that the ambulance came the [ __ ] some
people came with the beds there was a
small fire it shut that out and then
they sought her out and why she was
[ __ ] twisted oh but I'll never forget
these last words they were drinking
oh she said we were drinking though one
of the cops Oh said that they was
drinking yeah they were drinking and at
that moment me seeing that at that
[ __ ] moment as much as a criminal and
I [ __ ] around weed I bring on a plane
all these nonsense I do you'll never
ever ever see me drinking dry and it's
because of that night it's nothing to do
because I'm cool nothing to do yeah and
I saved my life
forever because I wouldn't mind having a
few drinks and get behind the car nobody
does but because I saw that I saw that
girl they took around the ambulance I
saw what she looked like
I saw the look in her face but the guy
she was with was dead but I guess as
they were putting him away and we were
talking the cop goes there was booze
they found like bottles in the [ __ ]
car
yeah and that was it that was it in mind
so if I got anything from all those
years of hanging out with the devil it
was not the drink and drive he says yeah
[ __ ] crazy and you can acid Boylan
and that's what we used to boil on acid
that's when you boiled on acid for eight
hours but you'd be high for 1343 likes
I'll never get drink and drive but let's
get in the car and drive home on Asus no
no no no we weren't drinking
oh you don't please there and some about
booze and [ __ ] you know people never
have you never hear bojong drive an ass
because I was doing asset you know acid
you'll fly through the air he'll give a
reason they say that your front of your
[ __ ] house oh my god it was it was I
don't remember the drive home with them
now I remember like I was shocked
Oh two or three days at that age I was
like jesus [ __ ] christ
I will that shake a guy like him too or
is he just sort of like bounced off of
that and like alright I killed his wife
yes wait think it did - no I didn't hang
out with him I stopped hanging out with
him maybe like summer of 81 because it
was just too much yeah you know he
called you seven nights a week and there
was always away and then blow up at the
end of the sky
and what we're gonna do with that scam
it was a small envelope I was gonna
spend the whole thing on drugs and then
Plus what yes what else added to drugs
with him so I put that line he put on
line I pull out on line he put on line I
pull out line he put on what and then we
take a line home by two flags and then
go home you know it was just a waste of
[ __ ] time it was a waste of [ __ ]
time yeah but you live in your land but
I remember him the moral of the story is
he took me to see the new barbarians and
the new barbarians you know what guys I
could sit here and tell you they did
their day I don't know what the [ __ ]
they saying I was just a kid I was just
happy to be out I was just happy a white
kid was talking to me I'm saying like I
was just happy but I do remember the end
that I showed that a triple encore and
at the end the people started throwing
the chairs up in the air the [ __ ]
guard and people started running other
people yeah they were ripping the chairs
out of the ground I was dead two times
when people start balling chairs no time
the Knicks were winning the Knicks were
covering the spread something happened
when I say when I say the Knicks were
losing the other team was covering the
spread and it makes were terrible in
those days and it was with the buzzer
was it explains threw the ball up in the
air back with the winning the Dyckman it
up covered so bunch of people that died
still a triplets head they bet on them
to lose is they better be a little yeah
[ __ ] hilarious cat like I said that
was there was a couple places I was a
child that were unique the other place I
went as a child with every time I went
to a six a game or a concert in Philly
always entertainment besides what you
were going to watch and that's what
that's what I liked about I don't you
don't have that anymore there's no more
challenge when you go out no war you
have oh boy you have you should be
having even more fun now with all but do
not be doing with
and now if you just had any old day
didn't have to worry about in about a
year some you're gonna wake up on
morning go oh my god Uber's gonna lose
again major cocaine distributor is
linked to Ober they were doing
deliveries a loop we're going to do I
got with uber cocaine cocaine will go
hand-in-hand Jack they get cooking at
midnight new but that's when they're out
lastly you get Luber in three [ __ ]
minutes what you want to go on you know
55th and lebombo Street I gotta go see
my grandma she was a reality it was I
like that's crazy
yeah or you gotta get away man right
then even if you sell coke you could
ever go to Lee's house drop it all over
again go back nobody knows the feds
can't really the feds will tap onto your
ventually chain follow your [ __ ]
little but let's go genius easier for
the follow you I was thinking they could
probably just have like a bunch of girls
or guys and they just called you before
them and they go to someone's house but
it's a just Co not same thing ya know
just let they never have to go the
prostitutes are probably making a killer
always making a killing off prostitution
yeah well you know kids do it now they
don't even pick the kids up at school
they send an uber for the kid that's
creepy as hell I've seen that out that I
can't imagine my mom would never do that
with me now she would well here's the
thing though and I'm just saying account
would you let your kid walk to school
feel like we walked us you did you walk
to school I bet I took a bus but that
was probably more dangerous than getting
a stranger to pick you up bring it in
your house stupid on a GPS when you ask
these questions don't look me in the eye
because I break down all this kid
related [ __ ] I live with a horror in my
heart then would I send my daughter when
she was six to spend the day of my
godmother on her 40s in Broadway and I
said then I start doubting my mom's
ability to make decisions because who
the [ __ ] would do that but guess what
that's why I learned what the [ __ ] I was
mmm-hmm and that's what you want from
your child yeah but means you don't have
the ball
to do that with our kids I'm the boss
trying to walk from where we live me
down to where she's gonna go to school
next year
guess what I'm gonna be a skinny [ __ ]
because I'm on the other line days a
week to week I don't even want to do
that through that it's good I'm scared
of a cognate went off the [ __ ] risk
better cuz I only stay on the outside I
would yell oh yeah your horse lady to
the inside you know these are the things
you [ __ ] worry about yeah that you
don't worry about before what's to stop
three or three guys in the white van
from bone overran time and kids yeah
and grabbing kids and take it off and by
the time even though the vans around and
they're Mexico up in Vancouver or
organization I mean these are the
realities of life guys this [ __ ] doesn't
happen you know it's like you always sit
there and watch TV gone look what
happened a kid got shot in the [ __ ]
heads on Crenshaw Boulevard you never
think it's gonna happen to you that's a
horrible way to live shake it happens in
time with that some of it you could
avoid and I still sit there all the time
ago how [ __ ] out of [ __ ] was I playing
basketball when I was 12 at 2:00 in the
morning la th Street Park where was the
supervision where was the supervision
put that again I made it to you know I
would see Patsy what is easy to my mom
no steam was she met a mother one time
she trusted Steve's mom good what about
her yeah it was those days there was no
reason to call no there was no reason to
call in those days so you know went over
there and next ninety ten everyone's
everything's working out yours our odds
that you're willing to take you're tired
you know I'm talking to leave before
miles go into the garden to see just
seven eighth grade to walk to the
Meadowlands from my house in North
Bergen to walk to the middle answer see
Ted Nugent Aerosmith
well I want my daughter on Route three
walking to the [ __ ] melons
these are the decisions I have to
thought I want to leave in my [ __ ]
side I love my wife but if you get my
wife and conversation you could steal
the sunglasses my wife ain't no [ __ ]
Jeannie you get a conversation you can
pickpocket I mean it's no [ __ ] the
big he's a big bottle of [ __ ] crazy I
know you have children you got a wire
everything Jesus Christ that 50-yard
walk well Steve you were just living on
the East Coast for a while yeah is it
different there what do you let him do
more than you would do here or is it
there they got on a bus they don't get a
new bus here I Drive my kids to school
every day guess what I don't like the
bus do it either
look at those bus people not at all
creepy they charge you 80 they pay the
bus driver 18 you know why cuz they
didn't get the hidden graduate from the
bus drivers Academy they hide that guy
he put like a check with why they call
the felonies a [ __ ] he's probably a
pedophile [ __ ] he's driving your kids
around yeah you don't better find no
more but eventually one day he'll snap I
will see a nice little [ __ ] chick
with a little scared on his [ __ ] that's
what you need in your life I'm scared of
all that [ __ ] right yeah and you want to
walk to and from school you know why
because how many times have you seen I'm
World News Tonight [ __ ] bus drivers
texting that's the trail of kids in the
[ __ ] car forget about it and it's
human nature and I can't it's against it
it's against me as an American to make
somebody put that [ __ ] phone away for
eight hours like you don't know him well
yeah if I owned the bus company and I
came to Steve when his agent said we see
what is easy he'll talk to you about
something when you check in at 8:00
give me the phone cuz lunch time I'll
give your phone back and at 12:00 you
give me your phone at 5:00 I'll give it
back to you mm-hm
how many people would do that just
because we can't do that because we have
families yeah you know you can't do
something like that no but on the other
end that's what you have to do as a
parent you have to go up does this guy
[ __ ] chitchat all day we have
Facebook live looking at flat chicks
getting beat they're [ __ ]
well like three or four years ago
there's a big like derailment on the
subway in Boston some guys
sting and he crashes sober if anyone
died but they definitely like broke arms
and it was terrible they have cameras
now watching them guys I got a buddy
from high school that works for the Long
Island Railroad he's the guy that when
you know your Penn Station everyone all
those people are swamping around that
thing looking to see what track the
thing is I text him I go what which
would I mean thing I'm going around
conquer with 21 boom I'm down there I'm
getting the [ __ ] beer I'm there when
the doors crack open boom I'm inside and
then if you go with him he's got the key
to the employee car you know the first
one the air-condition you can smoke
inside
they don't bust your balls right in
there great Penn Station is not that bad
no they're redoing a lot of it now I was
just there like I don't know
January December sometimes you run down
to Penn Station
you can't even miss a bus or a train you
get there you have a bumper and there's
a [ __ ] ball oh there's a lot of
things there now yeah I'm a [ __ ] term
away yeah good as you're waiting for the
train to two-step
yeah people are still calling yes yeah I
was like way to say right on the tracks
I have like an hour [ __ ] train I said
you know what who the [ __ ] am I let me
get a little black Ratanak yeah you know
vodka tonic with me goes a long way
that's two hours or something being
hammered google [ __ ] drooled all over
myself is [ __ ] voila
yeah I like that I didn't know that I
had no idea they had booze back when I
lived in New York for those we was
talking about when I did East like like
I did like Boston or failure I take the
train was easier I like yeah and the
trailer DC zxl a from Penn Station
listen you could reach the [ __ ] sky
get to Hong Kong from 10 stations you
can take a train from New York to Hong
Kong Cisco you can't get to LA important
time you get the same ones where you get
to Hong Kong and cut the whole [ __ ]
West Coast I enjoy the other one you
train for an hour
trust your Chinatown mix you know 12
hours later the mission you wake up and
is - dude they got beat up a good night
is that the [ __ ] terrible holiday
video
he's usually shy on disclosure now
he's doing public appearances nothing
like the [ __ ] missile King gentlemen
like this together oh my god
boom that dudes or the bond that he's
got a missile United gave him a missing
with most gave him the plane that he was
on I would take daddy God he wanted some
bowing algorithm that's all he wanted
God fake money I disclosed him oh yeah
undisclosed means nobody wants inside no
you know we can't even tell you but you
know what you were gonna kill us in
court anyway all they had to do it uh
write some regulations a passenger that
didn't let's go to the video that's
showing you dragging like Jesus I'm
[ __ ] good Monday good drag like Jesus
the nation of a second video in there
all bloody running OH who got the who is
this the Spielberg I got remember when
he would try to run back on he's run it
down up and down the aisle I just want
to go home I just want to go home god
that's what I was teaching
oh my [ __ ] he was just getting paid
mental anguish that picture with him
with the blood he looks like Bruce Lee
then for the drink
that's what he's got well there overs
well jurist sitting here just looking at
two pictures they couldn't have those
pictures out now any much longer him
busted out yeah yeah they could every
did the pictures were out there it was
just clinking jurors it was just
somebody was oh look at that there's no
way you're gonna find 12 people who
didn't see that picture unless they live
like a [ __ ] African some like them
that'll get the internet everybody saw
that poor Chinese man get beat so what
happens you go to court that's it that's
the end argument now it's the win
understand they offer the may hell knows
well that's it the video replay uh every
time they would say some I wouldn't say
what's that what are you saying eight
hundred dollars versus no when we hit
the button can't what you're saying
court I object I'm checked hit the video
oh shut it all I just be sounding that
video to the jurors do not reflect at
that video again you got it your honor
you know the poison he's guy he had a
problem he was a
and then maybe the ringtone of your
phone they also know for defamation of
character because they release that he
was a doctor and he got um he got us
suspended for yeah pharmaceutical a just
went in there with a list of [ __ ] they
wanted to unite it was a list of [ __ ]
right now
three white dudes [ __ ] man like a
receipt like fighting all professional
poker player two for a while he won like
two million dollars playing buzzer oh no
that money's gonna be gone then it
doesn't really matter what and the
checks got a cache in three days I go
right back to the Twitter I show the
[ __ ] oh yeah you get the video please
I will play this video and every
listener that's it I was just going then
going he wants a helicopter a plane
what's all those [ __ ] love Korean
meals if he ever want to fly again here
by himself on a plan of playing united
his family yeah they all fly by
themselves to plane everybody the first
class
Chinese music why grows a little [ __ ]
you want again and we will 5150 milk
cash money anyone wanting to [ __ ]
another and I want 10 bodyguards Chinese
conquest but they eat stars for
breakfast I'm telling you I would
[ __ ] go bananas if I was an attorney
I want I want that problem Godwin Joey
looks like that
that's because Israel I'm totally cost
me this week yeah sir we can't give you
marijuana as part of a settlement look
you know what my clients very fickle
right now he's on the fence at the
whether this is the right decision or
not we got to go back after the press in
a minute no no what are we gonna do
we gotta tie them up in a jacket okay
please get a flashbang to Vietnam yeah
we got a time up and put on the car with
American music and we gonna Sue's them
all the way to get sicknesses his mental
conditions at weekend yeah she got the
beat and so he thinks he's he thinks
she's from the Ming Dynasty right now
and I'm talking who names are coming
together machine I'll [ __ ] out
nothing this guy said in the [ __ ]
gold mine
piece he was sitting on a gold mine when
I saw them pulling him out
I go wow well everyone has a camera I
mean how many people know those they had
they had 10 12 different videos to
choose from every news outlet every news
outlet had 10 to 12 different angles oh
I got this is a better angle when he got
bashing remember the one where they
smashed his head onto the thing then
when we bring it down the aisle
then when he think I didn't warn where
he had on my [ __ ] leg running at him
then they got the other one word coming
that way it was like a [ __ ] it's a
brutal film it was amazing I just felt
bad for the poor united person who had
to ask for another volunteer like you
know like a day later like you know some
of other flights probably jammed up
she's got to get in the [ __ ] mic and
as perfect like a volunteer burnover
selves like she probably know apparently
people are now I kind of hang an
advantage here about that well what's up
the ten grand now you can get the 10
grand I say I wait till I whip my family
got five people four people we get eight
grand a pop all of us are out we didn't
get the NetJets for probably 20 grand
we're out the door I made just you know
25 grand done so I owe you four tickets
was easy you might get one for yourself
yeah Christmas Day Christmas Eve listen
next light not till next morning don't
matter because by the time I got home
the kids will be sleeping my mom be
sleep ten grands you got a four seasons
close by
cuz I only stay at four seasons yeah
yeah just open you
yeah with ten G's on Christmas Eve ha ha
what's 10 G's amongst friends on the
present ah
you're a nice four seasons you get the
state medallion ascend up to your room
they never given the Chinese doctor ten
grand
what do you mean you don't think they
would ever get like we'd never get to
that level if they were if didn't if
that never happened like if they were
could go up to that level the Chinese
not a flying no no yeah and if he does
fly United he just sits then goes
I've already been taking care of I just
say it for three days and I'm still
ahead of the game I can miss 18 flights
at 10 grand
I still got money to burn like a [ __ ]
animal
uh it's the cameras kill me the cameras
kill me there's nights I sit there and I
go what would I do if I was a criminal
oh not much you can do your walk out
your door yet you're on camera if you
walked more than 55 feet usually I mean
you walk past my house you're on camera
yeah you're on ring man yep that's it I
got to ring in the back I got ten rings
you gotta ring yeah you got a ring
because still and even if you got a
wardrobe on you put it on the news
they'll see you know the lights going on
in the backyard do away ahead of the
[ __ ] game we've got the double lights
why not I don't know if I had back then
I'm sure they did did you like I keep
every day on the news now I saw the ring
had a they keep they catch people
stealing packages are kazoos did you
ever do that never then one time I stole
mail because my friend healed my friend
money is some so I'm gonna get the money
and I stole a box with a stereo on it
and it was a Social Security check like
a tax refund check
I took the tax refund check because I
had to do it on the inside those days 83
84 he said tell me bring me whatever you
got I'm gonna hate for 20% but I cash
everything lately I said well yeah he
would cash you know it didn't matter I
brought him checks for years [ __ ]
amazing this is way before you know any
alarms there was a time when I tell me
the credit cards if you spend on the $50
it running and his rather that was
called run dilemma thief all I do is
spend on the fifty bucks
Oh seeds get that and the Chinese lunch
buffet every day like a [ __ ]
ching ching ching
ah you can either go for the 495 with a
diet coke or you get to 1095 or you
could eat with the spareribs we want oh
my god I'll take the spare ribs Jung
Chang it don't matter John Schlesinger
[ __ ]
and it'd be Craven when the car we get
decline they would still because your
card was never to electronically man it
that's why it's white right yeah they
sent him the 50 bucks they put your card
done and they run him pretty up and gave
it to the bank the bank didn't even
catch on I thought I got 20 of those
pink slips
hey that you owed him you know cuz you
it was for 95 for lunch you told my
friend for [ __ ] thinking a card
yeah home 10 because they were in on it
to the wins they take that right out
there yeah they don't give a [ __ ] you
weren't worried about like the bank
being like he goes to this Chinese lunch
every day
go get him slowly in those days there
was no big computer so by the time they
caught it she would be three months down
the road that was what it was in my mind
there was no computer I had a friend
that was gonna Bank of America let's say
in 1984 he was at a Bank of America he
would even borrow money he would put his
money and he would borrow like 50 grand
and he would go to five bags and put ten
thousand savings and leave it in there
for six months after six months he would
go into the bank and get a $10,000 loan
no like a 75-mile wrong on the ten
thousand that was in the bank to build
this credit hell on Fridays at 10 after
three he would go into that bank and
closed his account and take the money
out and then go to an ATM ten minutes
away
I'll go to a different Bank got an extra
75 four hours up that's how fast he was
moving he was a headache
I'm talking about 83 84 that's good yeah
I mean thinking about he's building
trust by giving him $10,000 for he would
give him 10 take a 75-mile alone against
a 10 and then go in their bank and close
the account and pull the 10 out
something [ __ ] ridiculous to you but
is easy yeah I see you saying they've
been playing alone and then he would go
to close out he's accountant before the
loan paperwork actually got finished he
would take back his ten but now he had a
car that said he had 75 or whatever
$7,500
limit but he would walk out there he
would have best ten and get back 1750
mm-hmm in six months and he do it four
times so he would do that time is five
so he would make 35 GS on a Friday and
he would do this in different states it
was [ __ ] amazing and never got caught
as he stopped before it got computerized
like that's what he said [ __ ] this yeah
he stopped way before that he's still
around today I believe the successful
life so real estate nobody knows nothing
and he started that real estate with
that money was scamming do you know not
to treat years he did that good a year
18 months good good for him I say oh I
mean we feel bad for the banks go [ __ ]
the banks it's all the bank on that
either the bank gave him the money the
bank took back the money or the other
bank that [ __ ] gave him the money who
gives a [ __ ]
it's all sure isn't it I mean not at all
FDIC insured I mean I think if you've
robbed the actual bank I think you've
got to physically rob the bank but with
the guns and whatever but you know [ __ ]
Jesus how many how many [ __ ] fees and
should have you paid for your entire
lives you know that's a drop in the
[ __ ] the pocket scam was there was a
little [ __ ] time that's not even like
small businesses getting her that's just
bank banks losing money look
cause the whole thing you know he did a
thousand things that won't subscribe but
that was one of the things he did and he
would wear this guy all timing scams I
guess what taper working stuffs
disguises apartments like everything he
had and I'd be under that name yeah so
he would work it six months he worked
like sometimes he would open up an
account under your name and put five
grand and then just leave it there for a
year and then take a loan then he would
pay half the loan he would build up
aliases he was always juicing always
uses didn't want to get to spit people
get all about you gotta be really smart
yeah a long to stairs like yeah and not
greedy
don't be bowed out and got into real
estate and he's about little older than
I am now he checks him maybe once a year
check said my uncle Joey and we chitchat
a little bit hello here from Danny B's
brother I don't know he's locked up they
got him under the jail that was a little
[ __ ] time ago when we first started
the podcast
what am I did dear friend Danny be on
Twitter has a brother that was crazy
since we were kids
since we were kids when we were 21 22
this kid was 14 and he was doing [ __ ]
that you would just sit there and go
what the [ __ ] you know he robbed the
bank one time what with a fishing line
I'm Friday night and a hook he away for
all the small businesses to put deposits
in banks oh and he would put the [ __ ]
hook with the fishing line and he took
the [ __ ] money out he threw the bag
away he took the cash and he got like 9
G so he saw a cab driver and he goes
give me a ride straight to Canada and he
gave the guy a loud tip that's how he
got caught oh I just put it together
they called a bunch of cab drivers that
were in that area you pick anybody
suspicious or this kid wasn't the 15 he
gave me a long thing and they got him in
Hawaii that's what it started awesome so
they did a bunch other crazy that's a
federal offense right out of a head of
our mail but he was doing other what he
was they were doing that for
everybody's 15 fishing line taken bank
deposit [ __ ] he'd be surprised but he
came out and he robbed the bank I don't
know what the [ __ ] he did this time but
he was never really there this poor kid
never really had a chance if you think
back and look I mean he was gone at 14
he was already smoking cigarettes you
know when they hear the back of
mushrooms hitting the little mushrooms
and we got home he's a [ __ ] kid this
is way before he even developed he was a
child
give him 14 he could have been [ __ ]
12 I put a quarter rounds a half ounce
of mushrooms on the table heat something
like potato chips it just be Stephanie's
[ __ ] crunchy things they were dry
easy Oh we go out there like what is
this thing he's like a brother believe
it's [ __ ] mushroom juice we were
worried about him we forgot we giggled
about it we left we come back the house
is blind worried about him we forgot
yeah laughter how long was that
transition from worried about to forget
well after a while you crack a couple
jokes you look at on these pails he's
okay you say [ __ ] it'll be fine by me
that you didn't know yeah are you fine
let's get out of here you know you get
out and we came back home that night all
the lights were off in house because the
lights we walk up the stairs that he
isn't living room just [ __ ] sitting
there he's 12 you know right huh he
looks over this like you know I'm not
high well I sure don't wear button that
was Tony Bennett Lee
[Music]
May first [ __ ] it was just
Christmas I wanna be round to pick up
the pieces when somebody breaks your
heart some somebody is twice as smart as
I
after all these years is still a
beautiful song but somebody who will
swear to be true as you used to do with
me
holy I got some shoutouts real quick
to my main man in Milwaukee I'll be
seeing you [ __ ] in two weeks
Matt ho Maya my main man in Secaucus
little Ryan Holloway Cassius Morris over
there and [ __ ] in Calgary running
things
Bobby Sheeran Austin with the Kobuk cash
podcast my man Greg powers and Lynn up
in Seattle keepin it together
Mike Stein and the one by one podcast
he's ready to be a [ __ ] dead
Philip rusty Boselli the OREA and always
the original Mad Max my man Holly Baz
making a [ __ ] American appearance
pretty [ __ ] soon oh cool
and I think I think one by one had a had
Willa Walker jr. on recently yeah I saw
that one by one podcast don't [ __ ]
around man
my key ain't playing games over there
what's up to disease you tell anybody
how are you so where were you last week
Columbus the week before were ya uh I
did that casino in Oklahoma what do you
think I like it second time I did it
that Lacey girl she's so lovely
yeah figured out if they treat you very
nicely you know they don't mess around
you get there you know the hotel is nice
they give you that nice little steak
house I got there then you do the gig
I'm out ate it you know four o'clock in
the morning five o'clock in the morning
home by 8:30 they were right people are
lovely take pictures of them after I'm
not a gambler anymore do you do I don't
do anything really into casinos so you
know what I get them like a milkshake on
the way home on the way back to the
[ __ ] room I'll take a lash oh you go
you go back to your room you'd be
compress you smoke it up with ya like no
stairs
you play a little [ __ ] wheel of
fortune I play wheel fortunate loving
you put a quarter in there everyone so
onto the three you go back to one three
then you don't know if they got real
live yet now you then just two surviving
on some wheel yeah of fortune BAM
there you go testing 40 quarters now you
got pipes look at you like front of I
look at you I'm not looking then I'm
looking to break the bank
I just need 40 quarters to kill time I
don't have to go back to my room or
watch the things on a pond man or Lord
orders one more episode I'm just killing
time on the stone this [ __ ] yeah Oh
father is all be at the casino I got a
whole pack of nicotine gum you know yeah
I'm rockin in Rome I got eight and nine
stars in me yo get a drink from the
weakest I don't know those glasses
always with me yeah they don't cause me
glasses in the casino a quick watch
glass yeah those quick wash glasses I
don't know Doug it's just I will
actually hot water won't touch working
windows is that all it is I never even
thought of yeah well you got stars in
you then you just need a bottle of water
let me VIP you're the Remy Martin will
you bet inside you have your head I'm
not in that room you're drinking [ __ ]
colletion what's those glasses they got
cool tops and all that [ __ ]
rich white people drink out of I don't
[ __ ] know a chalice you know the
rafts that's true we should no no not
cuz I'm Jewish thing I'm talking about
the [ __ ] I'm sayin about like a
centralized line what's the special
glass Baha'i balls no Jesus Christ when
you get married you think like these
chicks
they've been suckin mm vixen when they
get married a second invitation to their
wedding and they want a bottle a tour
Peyton allows it's because there's a
certain type of glass type of glass
crystal critter cell cristão whatever I
bet when you're in the five thousand
dollar room you drink another cristão
[ __ ] glasses but when you in the
[ __ ] regular population room the
general population
I've never taken one of those glass here
in my cocaine days damn it I would go to
the bar I just tell anybody this stuff
what's up you just do what how how
stupid do you have to be when you look
at those they look clean to me look if
those glasses yeah you can feel you see
the fingerprints of depression you can
see the breath of [ __ ] you can see
the last three losers you want yeah that
good last you can see when they drank
and they breathe that Camel Brett with
the with the nicotine into the glass
what gave that fog of fog a yellow then
I was also between their teeth and
between their armpits that's the [ __ ]
look at those glasses next I don't give
a [ __ ] they taken back there and they
steam clean those things with 59° those
things are still [ __ ] disgusting they
get five or six fingerprints a day okay
think about that can't ever drink do you
see one of the casinos I go to God
waited and shut down for a couple days
as you can see there you go the bicycle
convene on went oh really went as a day
it happened I try pull so they got
robbed didn't they no they think you're
wrong people running a money-laundering
scheme yeah oh that's what happened with
the bicycle club right here like
survived yeah I like penis embolism yeah
it's right in there downtown I'm not
really sure they Snuka gabriel iglesias
in 1998 used to run a comedy show there
Wednesday nights they pay 35 bucks and
you could didn't get the money to the
next day so next day after 5:00 you
gotta go down there and pick up to 35
bucks in the heart of traffic you know
what that's like down they have five of
the [ __ ] that pill oh yeah
bicycle club casino Lee you're lucky
sometimes you rely we know that oh yeah
already astir asked I remember he was
the first person ever told me if when we
played poker down there he would do it
you gotta get a person to walk you out
he came a little bit of money sorry what
um excuse me
come with me I think you walked ahead of
a guy walking out to his car yeah I
don't go with a couple hundred dollars
so I never but I don't know that we
would be a good reaso
you gonna hit the head with a pipe you
[ __ ] tool allows you like I should
have a thousand whatever work all the
clubs you get hit up in the Commerce car
I don't go to collar
oh I you go to commerce all the time the
secret high commerce those plays you
gotta go to date Commerce is where I got
like two like I need food
I hated that yeah sure you don't want
because you're a fool you have a little
bit like 30 re and I used to go midnight
we work no ego at midnight and if you
made your money buy you beat the rush
hour traffic in home by 6:00 a.m. but if
you didn't make your money you'd have to
stay like a little bit later
you know you otherwise you don't want to
leave at 8:00 you'll be sitting in
traffic the whole way home I don't know
how you guys could sit out there all
night we play for a lot of scary [ __ ] I
love it I play blackjack so I have to
learn poker oh really yeah but it's
creepy lay out the Chinese food not bad
as a bicycle yeah to be honest I have a
bid goodbye oh my gosh God we go he is
excuse me but the other one I'd been
there maybe 10 years ago when Rudy had
it and Chinese food wasn't [ __ ]
Chinatown but it wasn't yeah and wasn't
bad at least it was in the neighborhood
the bike I mean the hot what's the other
one Hollywood parks now not even there
anymore
no it's a nice the stadium now yeah
that's nice now the new ones yeah they
made it they made a new casino they owe
that but that's where the the stadium's
going the football yeah so they made the
casino two bullets put it speed banks I
was not yeah and then they have a San
Manuel I've been - oh really out there
now how is that that was actually pretty
nice at one time it's like a little
Vegas it's not bad expensive but just
don't get the talker that it was like
the worst tacos or even I started it
might have been lizard me I stopped
eating them it was terrible listenmi but
the black gangs good yeah I don't play
anything I'm playing like eight years
I'm not I'm doing no I know but I'm just
also like I'm tired after the shows now
I have no idea what the [ __ ] I'm doing
it takes someone who I know way too dark
I know I did like two or three times and
it wasn't for me one time I put money
down the blackjack table people yelled
at me nobody [ __ ] draws on 18 I just
something [ __ ] started then I eat you
blew the table sounds like what the [ __ ]
I don't know dick about dick you know
that's how I am a roulette I I learn a
little bit but then I always am you know
I'm stoned whatever I can't remember
what it is if I gotta learning you down
then people yet they hate you with the
stick don't touch this
like I yeah if I gotta learn to lose
money I don't know yeah I'd rather stay
stupid lose on my own then learn to lose
[ __ ] money you know you know I think
that a sweet wheel of fortune for your
help quarters but that's to say I could
put a 20 in a [ __ ] machine and you
know once this is over it's over I got
back to my room I couldn't do the same
with blow I couldn't do the same now
grows you can you tell that grows at
midnight with a bag a week come back at
6:00
see how many you left I'll make it dirty
well no six he's already I will probably
wait out a guy before me and while I'm
peeing
either they grow no dip it in that real
hot mustard from chance I love them us
oh my god well it burns like your
nostrils is [ __ ] on the first bite oh my
[ __ ] god
what you got going on when is easy was
that um no TV though buddies call these
[ __ ] no no right now he's nothing
right now we'll do some of you will see
what happens I did it's doing this new
um Chris Rock Sandler movie on Long
Island this summer so I'm gonna be out
there so hopefully there'll be something
in that but you know do stand-up I love
it I'm on the road doing the where am i
next a la jolla a couple weeks the 19th
of May and then um comics Mohegan Sun
first week of June 8th 9th and 10th what
was I leave was I atomic slip tell him
why I would just go pee real quick which
one no you were I believe you were at UM
Foxwoods but I couldn't move yeah it
would move from Fox with now it's at
Mohegan Sun right and he was at the
theater at Fox with every other fear
right ok that's for one night yeah that
was cool so and you're also doing a
podcast down now do my podcast here me
this book which um you're the producer
of man thank you very much very good job
at that well it's a it's a highly stars
to eat before you produce my podcast
usually zero
usually zero but I tonight it'll be 11
amazing
you know you normally do edible than
often I
you know what I haven't in a while I
have a little bit more recently because
it's just killer nights and stuff but um
yeah it definitely hits me differently
what is it like being Highlander kids
is it was hard you try not to do it it
uh depends on the situation like usually
it's like a you know like a late-night
situation or more of a controlled
environment we're going to watch a movie
or something like that I don't mind but
for me it's not that much - I don't lose
really my I'll never go like twenty two
hundred milligrams [ __ ] like now
nobody would you take a full edible
where you just like smoke a joint I'm
like I'm gonna go home - I could go home
right now and hang out and be fine right
okay but you know it's not like it's not
like every night thing but if I ate like
three more stars it would be a whole
different thing that would be a [ __ ]
a vibe I get of water
um that would be a different situation
you know yes uh I feel pretty [ __ ]
high I mean I ate more than you're
pretty I know I'm he was asking me about
edibles because I don't really eat
edibles that much I usually smoke or
vaporize
so thank you buddy okay grab one of
those uh BM chocolates you get a
chocolate these are perfectly perfect
this is good because you gets told you
get the munchies and eat those [ __ ]
BAM and it puts a different planet
leaves you finish your you know ah okay
what's a deficit Oh [ __ ] like nineteen
suppose oh yeah 19 stars that close to
it this is the book I brought you say
two lights books
oh my brother Sam [ __ ] yeah jewelry
Jenelle this is you brother that's a
good book I mean it was written by Bill
Kennison was another guy but did it
build his brother I goes his brother
there's chapters in there let me get the
chocolate here what am i [ __ ] often
what am i diabetic time her [ __ ]
gonna pay me no mind list this is uh
it's interesting it's his brother store
you know this guy had it all when I'm
[ __ ] Howard Stern and went to war with
Howard Stern [ __ ] you boys about to puke
oh uh hi
that's over here your cup of blueberries
good for you and keeps you regular yeah
man um folks about Houston yeah that's
where he started Houston right I mean I
know what oh boy
look building you have no idea people I
deal with look what oh my God look at
this this process laughs okay come on
hold on just do y'all next fear how
many's all 250 Castine holy [ __ ] no no
this won't eat my okay I don't Papa
Malone was brutal
okay it says 25 775 I had 20 to 75 I'm
doing okay now you must know you can
tender with 275 oh you gotta have an
even number what 75 and 25 that's an
even number zero I'll talk about one
myself you know I'm gonna let come you
think I'm afraid to the world by
yourself but look good
anyone can see maybe he'll kill and make
me puke in other ways you want to go
down like a 20 to 75 good what happens
you have to go to the hospital tonight
they ask him to exam 3 20 71 that's
terrible
why don't be like that's crazy that's no
one's ever you know he was never taken a
month like I was saying what what I
really liked about the book was they
talked about ball this story in the
fruit because they were so hungry
yeah grab poor and I remember how I
remember how the store was there for me
at that time I was a regular [ __ ] mm-hmm
so I was allowed to hang out there but
that was a time when if I went to the
store there was food at the store oh
[ __ ] it was going on through game on you
know I heard he used to buy when he's on
the road like doing [ __ ] concerts and
stuff he said order pizzas to the store
just haven't delivered
kinnison just for staff you know yeah
because a nurse you knew that what it
was like to go to the store and neither
o'clock and be hungry oh yeah and Fidel
you have the whole [ __ ] shift
how many some nights you like Lodge is
bought ten bucks and when disease and
get a sandwich on the way no but wait a
second game over I get two slices of
pizza maybe a third oh [ __ ] I just still
borrow a temple in disease I got a nice
breakfast coming really [ __ ] or so and
so you know brought in that [ __ ]
plate half the trailers on yeah because
you know it's be hey begot christened
and left it in the back and he just
slice off a [ __ ] piece throw it in
the microwave that was it yeah I got on
my shelf for a few
is I had that book and look before I
moved to Los Angeles I had that book and
I lost it when my car got towed I was in
my apartment the apartment got towed
that was one of the things they told so
somebody gave me this a couple years
back and I read it twice you know I got
the emotional stuff mm-hmm kasib was one
of the reasons like when I saw that
whole Rodney game you feel special
Kennison was a [ __ ] wild [ __ ]
and what he was doing at the store was a
complete different level like people
going to see him at midnight yeah they
would show up to go see him they would
show up to go see him which is a weird
thing when you do with midnight Kennison
was going up and there'd be musicians
and [ __ ] actors anybody who didn't
blow pretty much those years was models
which was everybody you know it was just
a lifestyle in the Sunset Boulevard to
be cool you had to go see Tennyson at
midnight you know how cool that is
for that to happen to a comic on Sunset
yeah
fearless you were good I didn't watch
everything go what else do we have to do
know is it get people down here but
Springsteen was here two times and I was
here last week you know [ __ ] like that
that's what people [ __ ] so that's
what he was going through but he also
talks about like going up there I mean
the fruit and the [ __ ] bartenders
chasing them out so it's a pretty
interesting book I hope you enjoy I'm
gonna definitely read it I read I try to
read a lot of comics I read I read a
couple of comedians I read norms I read
Artie Lange's Artie's was good you know
I've got some crazy stories in it but
there's a lot of stuff that I didn't
know about or I don't know about him so
then you know the stories that what I
can gather about the store aren't going
to be so amazing because I know we know
so much about it it's just it's such a
familiar place you know it's weird how
how many you I don't know how long is
bit of that I think his anniversary was
last week of the week before or the week
before I think it was 97 90 92 is so
gray or two or something like that yeah
I've always heard like you've always
heard about the people who was normal
people act tell you what you want to
hear about his days of the comedies for
April 29 ya see it was an anniversary
for year 92 yes sir um people always
tell you what uh what you want to hear
like Holly was a great dude man he was
so funny at the [ __ ] store it's funny
how I've had ten people come up to me
with those stories but the one who blew
my mind was Mitch he sure liked after
was said and done mm-hmm like this is
Mitzi shore 2003 Navy when she still had
a wits to and stuff yep we had a
conversation one night and when Sam's
name came up
she just everybody scattered and she
just went on a 20 minute quiet tirade to
me and what Sam had done to the store
and what Sam was doing at first but what
he had become you know that you know she
had heard stuff about a saint up on the
roof and crazy as it was just [ __ ]
craziness she goes I knew kind of what
was going on but in 101 was kind of
going and I could say you know four
hours I can but it just came back like a
lot of people who I got to meet with say
you don't worry I'll be honest here it
wasn't that go he was up at the store it
was kind of weird it was it got kind of
crazy like he got kinda this is
different in any situation as we saw
with Dane at the improv the last factory
a comic becomes too comfortable and so
minty and he was bad and then he got a
billboard across the street from it see
was it something on it that
that someone she looked out the window
she saw his billboard he shot a gun up
there there's still a hole and the
[ __ ] thing where he shot the gun up
there yeah yeah there's just a lot of
things you know at first he was the
coming of and then Mitch he said that
was just really weird how everybody got
up there the click that had become and
once she died he died the way she was
happy because that click broke up and
she wanted to break it up she just
didn't know how she was going to do it
because how can you throw Sam huh yeah
but it was funny that she had banned Sam
Sam was banned I think at the time of
his death
well she banned a lot of [ __ ] people
and you know so I mean like I totally
see her van impe you know that was her
way of being like you're not you know
that's your penalty you know how much
you want to be here I know how much you
want to be here and how much you love
performing so you can't come here and
that was [ __ ] probably you know it
probably having multiple times she would
have been near a ban you I never got
banned either no no no I was always on
my best behavior I mean I got put in the
[ __ ] penalty box plenty of times of
like no spots for a couple weeks I think
I put the penalty box once or twice up
there but never know I was always cool
with me I was very getting past for me
was a [ __ ] took me a couple years on
more than a couple years well yeah like
four years three years but my friends
having a open-heart surgery on the
seventh my wife is leaving for a week I
do Bradley 8th 9th 10th I got a free
ticket from Virgil I gotta use before
July but he told me last week he was
having open heart surgery I said you
know I'm gonna take that to go visit
nobody loses he's my childhood friend
when I can I go say hello in surprising
he says only gonna be there for five
days so I gotta wait till Tuesday to my
wife comes back I just can't get on a
[ __ ] plane the next day if she gets
back after a week and I'd say that
[ __ ] kid yeah so by that time he'll
be out of the house beautiful I'm kind
of upset about it but at the same time
if God wants me there he'll put me there
that's just so we got a look at pic
sometimes if you can't get pissed off so
where we have to fly to Newark Newark
that's what virgin would make me into
yeah the return flight reversion is a
[ __ ]
what are you getting a bag one o'clock
oh really - wait Newark direct here and
you go look at that term we got some
good ass crab cakes with two eggs
sunny-side up yes these are world-class
crab cakes you could use order them let
them sent to your house while you're at
the [ __ ] Airport that's how strong
they are
everybody stay find or divergent they're
gonna get and get the two eggs the two
crab cakes we get it - piece of wheat
toast you're not walking out of it you
get on the play whether you [ __ ] take
a nappy noodle so great it you're
misusing the TV show uh yeah I miss
working like I like a regular schedule
for a little bit when you first got the
full-time gig on TV I wanted to take you
to get acclimated to the schedule a
couple well the the single I'd only
never done like those single camera
shows that are shot you know like long
days so I kind of as used to that
everyone was sort of used to that I
never did a four camera in front of an
audience show so those hours are real
short and kind of easy but uh took me it
took me a couple weeks to get used to
like the schedule of like what we were
going to do and how long we're going to
work and then it got me it took me about
two years to get used to like how I'm
going to split my ear up you know I'm
gonna write well I'm going to shoot the
shell for like four months I'm gonna
tour for four months
I'm going to try to do like a movie or
something else for a month you like try
to break it down it took me like a
little bit of time to figure out like
how to break down my year I like a
schedule and I like sort of that's how I
like to break down you know how I work
so you know for me took me about two
years to figure that out it just takes a
period of it's a few weeks ago that's
for camera right yeah yeah this is
they're like [ __ ] zip zooms that easy
your ass out of that gray catering so
weird are you sitting oh do I want to do
this full-time at this age in the movie
you know I could do some of the hoopla
some of the hoop was that necessary
the thing about it like you said you
gained 20 pounds of season but the
bagels the locks and the [ __ ] they
had everything like everything great
catering they have the espresso machine
double espressos you know uncle Joey's
banging out with your stevia well
[ __ ] thirsty now the third shakin
hands of you hey I already have
expresses [ __ ]
they had soda machines filled with stuff
I thought about Li so one day I was
there that cheese enchiladas and Korean
barbecue that looked like somebody spray
paint I didn't touch it
Thank You Alan touch that [ __ ] listen to
meet somebody it spray-painted I stuck
with the cheese I chill out I know those
[ __ ] people younam's and cheese
enchiladas got more [ __ ] credibility
than Korean barbecue of my world yeah
Miguel and I love Mexican mm [ __ ]
years for Koreans I can be around lately
the dud the whole [ __ ] thing good good
dud
the second buds are oh yeah they're not
gonna get that well he's gonna keep
firing up those duds so he gets one to
stay up but that's scary
I hate although what I'm gonna [ __ ] this
morning no they don't know what they
can't get it in the air you think you
know what's gonna [ __ ] your land I can
land in the Jersey they don't give a
Frenchman's [ __ ] jack I totally feel ey
you don't train on the weekend well
knowing that we were 25 I'm fine and you
leave him one
is on Mon going up I'll call you
tomorrow morning is still sleeping at
then what happened I never sleep all
tense are you sleeping oh my oldest coal
and [ __ ] well useful you stay at Holly
we stay up till tonight
five four or five man yeah look that's
why he's heading to another stop see if
you did what's the number again 20 to 75
please just do a red one no I have
another push at 2400 even if you just do
a little 120 32 say what's the
difference at this point 20 to 75 2400
it was a [ __ ] count hanging in for a
pound
yeah sure you're as tough example mix a
little chocolate I'm gonna say a little
chocolate red star cherry with the
chocolate you could sell that [ __ ] Lee
mix a star with a [ __ ] chocolate bomb
bun calling Lee's you just gave away the
seacrest me yeah and I wanna [ __ ] up
what's the last book you've read that
you like I just read out of this book
the hike on we were on vacation for a
week it just it was just crazy story
that my friend Paul told me about this
guy goes on a business trip right normal
family wife two kids decent life goes on
a business trip checks into the hotel
you know the key everything that we go
through many got here's a meeting at
like 7:30 to dinner
it's like one o'clock because I'm gonna
go for a hike any trails so lady goes
yeah there's one up back there he goes
up on a trail ding bing bang boom he
could still see the hotels and he sees
these guys killing this guy and then he
locked eyes with him and he runs and he
starts he just runs the other direction
they're running after him he gets lost
turned around before you know it he's in
this [ __ ] crazy like mind-bending
dream world where he's now like walking
around I mean he gets crazy he becomes a
crab dimensions he's gone for what feels
like hundreds and hundreds of years
he meets himself constantly in different
forms and at the end he gets like
basically a decent life ahead of him and
he gets a choice like do you want to go
back to your life that you had before or
like you can be a ruler here and he
chooses to go back not knowing at all
what the consequences are
you know then he goes back it's it's
pretty [ __ ] it was crazy he was like
a you know a two and a half day read I
didn't you don't learn anything just
kind of a nice little mind-bending trip
just some real employee yeah but I've
never really read those before I always
just read biographies so it's funny that
I have a my office I have like a
computer with a desk and I was up on a
wall I have like pictures um health
street pictures of my friends who I grew
up with and high school teachers and
just regular [ __ ] that most people
wouldn't have I just keep it as a
reminder in a way but it's so weird
sometimes I get stoned and I'll be
[ __ ] on the computer or maybe on
Facebook returning messages or whatever
and I'll look at those pictures and
something will frustrate me and I'll go
you know like it really doesn't matter
because someday I'm gonna go home mmm
like in my mind for five minutes I
actually believe that one day I'm gonna
stop doing what I'm doing I'm gonna go
back to my burger that's gonna be just
how it was not he's across the street
the Clemens is down the block with crabs
of the corner Frank the fruit and [ __ ]
Grayson
that is a guy that is Frank the fruit
yeah
Grayson would be great Savoy licences
and fruit yeah like you know you know we
lived in it I enjoy I know what the [ __ ]
am I thinking about but yeah the [ __ ] is
my and then I go mister wait a second
would that be an interesting thought if
you can live and at one point they come
back to you and go you know what my girl
Frankie we love it and you guys broke up
because she wanted to join the army he
meets a girl like that on the on the
trigger he's like I really tempted yes
why do you always say that to give you a
chance
yeah to go back or stay what you got now
and usually we have now a beautiful
family hmm two kids a great wife yeah
like you got a great life but what if
what if for the sake of argument what if
he's able to stay with that girl you
know like this is the [ __ ] sometimes at
night when I'm writing I'm like yeah
like I'm just gonna stop while I'm doing
and go right back to North Bergen 1980 I
get the back of my mind today it's still
[ __ ] exist somewhere in a deep deep
[ __ ] corner that still exists in my
mother I swear to you yeah I'm gonna
stop doing what I'm doing and just go
home yeah and just go home which home
will be [ __ ] but I'm dead I'll be
buried over there we talking cemetery so
I'll be right down there by giving that
Terrace hahaha god forbid well if you
got going on that said to the road right
you only got happy now but because life
gets real Jack yeah but the parents do
that to every now we talk we talk about
like they have their plots picked out
but my mother will go off she'll tell
you exactly what coordinates choose mom
in fees.com NC 38 your father's in the
sea 39
they're next to each other so it's not a
long walk from the parking lot so you
won't have to worry about you know when
you come to visit me and you will how
far it is you know she
my mom likes to she lives in that misery
that's like heard her neutral when
you're 28 you see an advertiser for
financial creator on you like [ __ ] that
if I die let my [ __ ] family pay for
it those miserable [ __ ] yeah when you
get 50 you go hmm why don't I pay for it
just in case one of these miserable [ __ ]
doesn't come up with the money I just
want to die in peace
yeah that's when you become really crazy
when you actually go out there and pay
for your funeral in advance there's some
part of me that that is [ __ ] crazy
what's answer that like me walking down
in Ohio mr. Pontecorvo listen I don't
know what I'm gonna go my feet hurt I
got a slight even my [ __ ] neck oh
[ __ ] all signs of saying that yet either
I'm doing this now or someone's coming
by but you're doing a Greta glut number
what's the vague for me paying this out
front right yeah give me a window you go
with your loving son oh oh yeah give me
a win you give me a cash number please
some will give you a soup pretty soon
you guys are limo and I'm all right by
this news limo drive and we prepaid this
one the [ __ ] I want to tip you for the
flower guy you know why cuz that's how I
roll it's a poly colville like that's
the point when you're [ __ ] nuts Lee
I've told you this mmm life gets real
when he has 50 that's when life begins
the rest of this [ __ ] is [ __ ] if you
take out what I told you this 30 years
ago you crazy once I hit 50 I got a life
it's crazy done with the baby praying
but wounded is that we both look at each
other no attack I love it I love us just
it's too different I was talking to the
[ __ ] hypnotist tonight cuz I went to
the hypnotist time with one of my fears
with your horse feels like you don't
understand other bad
family like this we go the park like the
human beings we cheese and crackers at
the party [ __ ] like with Gentiles yes
cheesy music covered raises yeah we got
to beat styles out like Puerto Rican see
my wife forgot the big picnic table the
picked a [ __ ] blanket so my daughter
goes go hit the mic and mommy she goes
always come back with to [ __ ] down
like what happened
you forgot you come there today yeah
yeah yeah and kids been talking about
all morning he forgot about the fight he
begged me pick me
it was crazy because I had my jujitsu
bag and everything I'm gonna go back to
the hypnotist in jujitsu I called my
wife Sheila lizard I know what you guys
talked about this morning she wanted to
smack it you know she's not eating till
daddy gets here
did you tell you when we go to document
come here I go I don't know what the
[ __ ] I told her but I guess I'll go god
damn Parker go jiu-jitsu Tuesday
Wednesday and Thursday so I tried did
today
it's just really interesting mm-hmm it's
I can't imagine with two my husband's up
here it's a lot well next year thank
goodness to go to the same school right
now it's like you got they go to
different schools so you pick up pick up
drop off one drop off the other pick up
one pick up the other my mom my wife
suck-ups you know a bus service back and
forth but yeah it's a lot my youngest
turns five tomorrow
it's his birthday leaves a little
tomorrow we go to dinner you know we're
going to like the pizza place he likes
down the corner and then Sunday little
party at the park for later on how you
go you want to ask you let's go to we
don't want any more than the dead can
you bring him up you only got more than
we get you stay yeah now I was like you
say Paris I saw the pizza plate was my
brother yeah you but if you like it yeah
we'll do it
I started gold McDonald's with my
daughter last year yeah and every time I
go I see you for what the [ __ ] it is and
I tried to switch it up what do you get
I always get the same [ __ ] for less
every time I go to McDonald's the last
50 years I've got the same [ __ ] when I
was a kid you only got an option at a
big pay
makya I disappeared from McDonald scenes
from a few years and when I made a
comeback to has been called the quarter
pounder with cheese huh I didn't like to
add a stick my fingers in the same would
you pull the pickle
oh it ain't no pickles now you can but
that's what he using I love to go to
pound get pickle and [ __ ] spit no you
could sound [ __ ] pickle on [ __ ]
haha so but I started going back on my
daughter what does she get what do you
think they get the chicken nuggets right
yeah the Nuggets that [ __ ] the guys
meal that's why people become tougher to
listen it good I wouldn't think we hit
we discourage it and now the Black Hawk
Down you're gonna get you gotta get a
McDonald runnable every 10 days
yeah I'm doing McDonald Run 1 every time
they had that come to terms of that it's
when you're taking your kid near three
nights a row oh yeah where it's a
[ __ ] problem in the Rema cribs Donal
that [ __ ] that got those eyeballs and a
pigeon tails is [ __ ] you know you know
what themself yeah you know what the
[ __ ] you're even those things so you
know after she plays soccer and so how
there we go yeah I get the whopper jr. I
want to live about three months ago when
they had the big my junior not one patty
it's a little small oh really
and it's uni picnic it was delicious
yeah I can't watch it was delicious for
about two times and then he said I went
Y and Dan got it and I'm like ah right
taste this [ __ ] yeah this is bad news
is horse meat no [ __ ] isn't straight up
or is you Claus no one I can't do
anymore as Taco Bell I used to love
Tagum I shouldn't be able to do that for
the last 10 [ __ ] years
there's too much good stuff out here but
I still Taco Bell is like a weakness of
mine really not a weakness of mine 100%
but like I wouldn't go there hot my
first choice but I could still do it if
I had to it's so funny how it's around
the corner from where I live and I was
not gonna be a one-time but I would
rather get one on the street from any
Street place igniters was not saying
like the tacos from the
before he lights and tacos and
McDonald's is that way you get over no I
don't know I never had McDonald did Taco
the McDonald's
no a Taco Bell what the [ __ ] am I say
looks old Oh taco bell's got ya they got
goes yeah they got like coilette so yeah
you like three tacos for like a dollar
50 okay so we got that and I like the
burrito supreme bliss is that what it's
called yeah but here's the thing I only
go when I'm stoned late at night and
late at night they have like all the
things are stale although the raps are
always stale the wraps are still wrapped
you know like the would they be taco
shell maybe get this soft taco you know
the corners the all that the outside is
all I wasn't really part in this book
I've gotten the whole thing stuff guys
even black acos Dale and then hard tacos
be still a bro I Drive past that place
and with all the nutrition information
that goes out blah blah blah blah blah
blah there's a line around the [ __ ]
corner constantly the next to a Thai
place and that [ __ ] Thai place
they're out there young screaming half
the [ __ ] time shut the [ __ ] doors
no you're killing me who's gonna eat
this [ __ ] [ __ ] when you people come
in here in this Taco Bell and it's
really that meat correct like now I'm
done with it it's showing me I don't
know
it was a prison so percentage mean it's
where there's some meat in it but
there's other stuff in it too you know
it should all be meat right it should be
you know
what do you think it's in there beside
the me as you're in Italy it's 2:00 in
the morning you're throwing down ten
tacos and you're chewing through that
meat
what are you really thinking your heart
like are you I'm just curious
I mean holy when you realize Taco Bell
you eat somebody's foot and it's with me
look at the look on this way I would
probably say and be like you had
probably like camel me so what did you
realize that was animal me from that but
that it's delicious so let me read back
the little think about it I have had for
a while while oh you have but you did
while you were having it no of course
you never drink about a wine sauce now
just Christ I mean somebody's toenail is
rounded up over this beef that's what
kills me that I just listen I know that
you eat [ __ ] everywhere even when you're
not cooking I said no sorry about that
there's a lot of [ __ ] out there you know
you have to cook for yourself you don't
know what the [ __ ] they're putting in
there or giving you for that sense but
with Taco Bell you though going in there
giving you soy meat and 30% of [ __ ]
some cows shoulder I got shot during the
war
the meat is mafia meat a grinder you
know they're cutting corners all that
stuff sure they cut corners that's how
their corporate that's how they make a
profit
he's on my charge you made this news
it's just a I love their sour cream they
have the best sour cream in the business
title Mel the [ __ ] best that's why I
get it but they it's not good I put too
much now I like to the tacos with the
sour cream and I love de marido supreme
with sour cream it's how to be ten
fifteen years as I had talked about it's
not as good anymore no no I would never
watch my taco tonight and she didn't
she's not great at that well you'd like
the East Coast kind like they can be
fanatically yeah because they cook the
ground beef like it's a Hamburg exactly
that's easy
they don't do nothing they cook it they
look at ya yeah the cuff you know they
put it on top she's worried about she's
cutting the you know the cheese up the
right way and I can wait oh and lettuce
can you worry about the meat a little
more than no flavor you got dope up to
me let's don't put a bunch on it before
we put it in there let's cuddle up let's
get to taco seasoning
let's go on wine was good to look for
some nice taco meat different [ __ ]
preparations here oh my god
I'm sorry guys I'm just long the [ __ ]
high side so what the data's coming up
does um I'm going yeah so the whole
economy story May 19th and 20th and
comics in Mohegan Sun June 8th 9th and
10th and I'll be on the East Coast for a
little bit doing something in July two
hunts Vil Alabama going to that Club the
stand-up live down there I'll be there
next year
alright I'll be there in August because
I did Asheville this year because that's
what I wanted to happen national yeah so
break them up do one do the other one
[ __ ] around
mm-hmm why take your chances [ __ ] yeah
what's going on Lee how you feeling
you're feeling good aren't you look at
you absolutely you're happy you showed
up as [ __ ] it's [ __ ] Monday May 1st
the rent is due
you got to be on [ __ ] point the rest
of the goddamn month like I said to you
this weekend I met wise guys in Salt
Lake City who the [ __ ] you think you're
dealing with
Mormons strapped a pair on the Mexicans
will be out Friday but Cinco de [ __ ]
Myo in Salt Lake City will Eve nuts
Saturday I'll be there again for two
shows then the following week Detroit is
done so you got to go with [ __ ] the
Turner Ballroom in Norwalk e there's a
couple tickets left don't [ __ ] around
I'll see you guys either or and that's
that [ __ ] I'm happy you tuned
in to the church tonight I'm happy
Stevens easy came by thank you for
having me but I better get the book
brother Sam so when Steve covers on his
show you guys could follow it and then
look through the books in case I got no
time to take over the world
I write notes the mall manager and
[ __ ] oh god I hope that there is and
you'll see the plan I'm gonna get come
over go away I found a card and the
whole [ __ ] thinking what type of
causes my Castellano don't tell their
names
no names nothing no [ __ ] things we do
this card is e like I said people give
me a oh yeah this guy's long ago
hahahahaha this poor person
I found the CEO call this number what do
you want to make a bet this thing is
done this [ __ ] tape thank you buddy
for give me the book
absolutely again the show brought to you
by on it go to Hana calm right now and
get 10% off any of their supplements
with alpha brain you get 100% money-back
guarantee if you don't like it you know
what I'm not operate right now I swear
to god [ __ ] yeah give a little alpha
brain a try see how good and how focused
you're gonna feel go to on it back time
right now president Church BAM ten
percent off the Liberty house who's
better than you whether it's the shrimp
export the new mood whatever the hell
you're doing this will help your game
out on a comm number two are you hiring
do you know where to post your job to
find the best candidates posting a job
in one place isn't enough to find
quality candidates if you want to find
the perfect high you need to post your
job on all the top job sites and now you
can with dip recruiting calm you can
post your job to 100 plus job site
including social media networks like
Facebook and Twitter all with a single
click first candidates in any city
industry nationwide just post once and
watch your qualified candidates roll in
two zip recruiters easy to use interface
no juggling emails or calls to your
office or people bothering you showing
up quickly screen candidates rate them
and hire the right person fast and
efficiently find out today why zip
recruiter has been used by Fortune 100
companies and thousands of small and
medium-sized businesses and right now
right now today my listeners the family
of the church can post jobs on zip
recruiters for free by going to zip
recruiter dot-com slash church CH you
are CH BAM that zip recruiter calm slash
church one more time
by it for free go to zip recruiter
dot-com slash Church this is the way to
go this is the future number two listen
Mother's Day is coming you ever sit
there you're cooking you go to your
mother's house your brothers are there
your sisters damn and yes this has got a
[ __ ] boyfriend to lose it
he beats around the weekends you don't
know you don't know but while your mom
is cooking you're looking at her ass you
don't catch a look at your mom's ass and
ask yourself do you think your mama's a
smuggling give or take that you ever
take that to the next level just look at
your mom's biggest time ago I wouldn't
be [ __ ] right now
god forbid oh my god Mother's Day is
coming why take the chance you don't
want your mom to have a stinky [ __ ]
well if she goes to Bing no she gets
picked up by a Latin love and he dips
into a [ __ ] muffler and it stinks
like the pens and fruit cocktail is that
what you want your mother's ass gonna
smell like [ __ ] no Martha the days of
back [ __ ] listen hello to ChiCom
portable bidets fit in your bathroom my
god you'll never feel better than you
ever did before in your life you'll feel
confident you leave the house no more
[ __ ] toilet paper there's no trees
getting [ __ ] up in the jungles you're
just living off water they also have
little towels available that you can
wash and dry later on you just sprinkle
a little water into your little muffler
it takes away all the little [ __ ]
star media and lettuce and God does it
out it's hanging some big Nancy Mother's
[ __ ] you're done sadly this is why go
to hell a cushy calm right now and press
in charge BAM Church
CH you are CH 10% off a porter for a day
for Mother's Day
trust me this weekend when you are your
mother's date look at her ass ask
yourself well I like that [ __ ] thing
for this ball 20 no young man and you
know it smells like a [ __ ] billy
goats [ __ ] give it a bad day
listen you avoid a bunch of stuff it
cleans the colon it cleans all the
[ __ ] things everything anyway
do me a favor white [ __ ] around and
talk about the diseases the [ __ ] I'm
trying to sprinkle humor into this Eddie
do yourself a favor go - hello - she
calm right now I'm pressing Church
BAM ten percent or portable devices
60-day money-back guarantee it's like
having a [ __ ] spit living in toilet
just spitting up into the air so you
know what that feels like going on you
want that feeling go - hello - she calm
right now and press in charge boom I
want to thank on it I want to thank
support good calm I want to thank Steve
others easy and I want to thank Tom
hello pushy calm for keeping [ __ ]
clean all over the country you
understand me
that's the most important thing so you
[ __ ] Wednesday night stay black I
love you you know we don't [ __ ] around I
love us job knowledge everything - I'm
John - your [ __ ] 1980 [ __ ]
food
you know what it's like because like
when Aviva decide
I go no dice to jump on you you whine
about the review hi behind that Matthew
you and did you think the Google level
with we need to me I'm coming back up
skin I gotta take good love ever smell
for it and you know
never could hold do it stopping down the
road believe in me I can but you made
for medicham uses our be my community
I'll still stand this path to all these
sides picking up the be feel of my life
without you on my mind I'm still
standing
I'm still standing
I'm still standing there azmuth the
mother to survival
give us a visa
dad
I'm just
[Music]